[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous dans ce
cadre impressionnant de l'as al de baume
transformée en salle des ventes
une fois par an pour la prestigieuse
vente des vins des hospices un cadre
idéal pour notre question du jour le vin
de bourgogne est il devenu un produit de
luxe
une question qui se pose depuis un
certain temps qui s'est posé avec encore
plus d'acuité ces dernières semaines
avec le rachat du célèbre claude tard
par le milliardaire françois pinault
pour un montant évalué à 250 millions
une question que nous allons poser nos
trois invités pierre henri gagey bonjour
je veux vous êtes négociants et vous
êtes membre du bureau interprofessionnel
des vins de bourgogne
jérôme gallot bonjour bonjour vous êtes
enseignant directeur de la school of
wine and spirits business de bsb belle
école de commerce de dijon et laurent
gotti bonjour bonjour lien journalistes
grands spécialistes de la bourgogne avec
votre site all about burgundy donc
question simple à vous trois pourquoi
comment pierre henri gagey 7 hectares de
vignes peuvent-ils valoir 250 millions
ça paraît ça paraît dingue ça paraît
extravagant mais c'est tellement
extraordinaire d'ailleurs qu'on qu'on a
du mal à donner une vraie réponse c'est
un truc qui qui nous dépasse tous mais
qui est liée à la rareté un phénomène
exceptionnel de claude tard est un
monopole n'a appartenu à trois
propriétaires en cinq ou six cents ans
et c'est quelque chose d'unique
mais c'est une suite il ya eu d'autres
domaines vendu très cher juste avant
l'heure les connaisseurs verne et
embraye en a eu d'autres et les prix
montent
c'est vrai mais là on a affaire
l'étroite les trois domaines dont vous
parlez le sol et l'ambré le claude tard
et ponot du martray sont trois de même
exceptionnel il y en a où ça y'en a pas
tant que ça
en bourgogne des domaines où il y a
quasiment que des grands crus et en
superficie qui sont très importantes
avec la même appellation
ça se compte sur les doigts de deux
mains alors certes ça fait trois d'un
coup qui se succèdent mais
mais c'est quand même très très peu dans
les temps la grande bourgogne cc 2 3%
c'est ridicule c'est tout
on va essayer effectivement d'aller en
profondeur laurent quand on dit que les
prix augmenteront tu sais c'est quelque
chose dont on parle beaucoup dans le
vignoble dans les vignerons parle
beaucoup
le prix des terres le prix du foncier
oui tout à fait alors on se demande
comment on peut mettre aussi chiendent
dans sept hectares de vignes mais alors
une petite information c'est qu'il y
avait des acheteurs étrangers qui
potentiellement était prêt à renchérir
soit de la somme qui a été donné donc la
famille a préféré que le cloclo reste
français en tout cas propriétaire de
dinde un français et donc on aurait pu
avoir une somme plus extravagantes
le marché s'est effectivement des
acheteurs et des vendeurs et il se
trouve qu'il ya des acheteurs qui sont
prêts à tout simplement à mettre des
prix incroyables mais c'est la
rentabilité économique effectivement en
tout cas à moyen terme est un peu
compliquée à obtenir
jérôme gallot qu'est ce qui explique en
termes de mécanismes un achat aussi
élevé parce que c'est prestigieux comme
le dit pierre henry gagey ou parce
qu'aussi aujourd'hui il ya une demande
mondiale extrêmement élevé une offre
réduite et des primes ou taye déjà très
élevé qui permettent on va dire de se
refaire sur ce prix effectivement si on
traite la question d'un point de vue
strictement économique le prix d'un bien
d'un service dépend toujours un moment
donné de la du pouvoir d'achat de celui
qui va l'emporter
c'est comme le jeu des enchères si vous
voulez sur ebay même si la comparaison
est un petit peu forte
quelle que soit la valeur intrinsèque du
produit à valeur symbolique la valeur en
termes d' usage
le prix de marché va être défini par
celui qui est le dernier à dire et à
payer
voilà alors là où votre question est
particulièrement intéressante c'est que
finalement ça nous ramène à une question
qui est une question relative aux
produits
est ce que le vin et en particulier le
vin de bourgogne est évidemment les
domaines des prestigieux domaine les
terres sont des produits économiques des
biens économiques comme les autres je ne
crois pas et à la question est ce que le
vin de bourgogne est devenu un produit
de luxe
d'un point de vue économique on peut
dire effectivement qu'il a un certain
nombre d'atouts d'attrait d'attributs
qui le renvoie à des produits de luxe
très bien identifiés comme des voitures
de luxe comme des sacs de luxe des
bijoux mais il porte en lui à mon sens
est particulièrement bourgogne des
attributs qui sont des attributs
beaucoup plus symbolique quasiment de
l'ordre du sacré et de la métaphysique
et de ce point de vue là quel est le
prix que vous pouvez donner à quelque
chose qui relève d'une dimension comme
celle ci avec un produit quand même
temps à des valeurs de convivialité de
partage et de choses comme ça qui sont
peut-être un peu antagoniste avec avec
le produit de luxe laurent vous vouliez
ou les réagir non non je pour moi le
banc après quelle définition de nos
produits luxe effectivement et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le produit de luxe c'est
justement pour moi c'est pas un produit
c'est une expérience en fait et quand on
vient en bourgogne quand on goûte un vin
de bourgogne c'est pas du vin qu'on boit
c'est une expérience et une
c'est une histoire c'est une émotion
c'est du partage
voilà c'est un temps donné qui on le
sait quand on ouvre une bouteille ça
sera un temps unique partagé un moment
ludique
moi je vous reprends en bon laurent un
grand cru dans les années 90 ça valait
100 francs 150 francs aujourd'hui un
grand cru si si si c'était à peu près
ses prix la pyramide des âges est
aujourd'hui ça vaut entre 150 euros et
puis ça peut monter pour les plus
spéculatifs on est d'accord c'est une ou
deux mains à 1000 euros pour certaines
bouteilles quand elle passe par des
intermédiaires
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui est en train
de complètement transformer les choses
et est-ce que c'était une bonne idée de
laisser filer en même temps est ce qu'on
pouvait faire autrement
on peut bien sûr pas faire autrement on
peut pas contrôler je vais demander à
des gens de vendre a dit ce qui peut
vendre à son nom mais c'est mais c'est
même pas ça même si nous vendons à 10
l'acheteur terminal hyper à 100 parce
que c'est un jeu d'offre et de demande
qui ce qui est un jeu mondial et c'est
ce qui a changé un peu depuis 90 des
nouveaux arrivants sur le marché des tas
de gens qui sont fortunés on l'entend
tous les jours on nous dit des grandes
fortunes et sont de plus en plus
aujourd'hui dans cette vente des
hospices on est encore au coeur de saint
robert où les monnaies journée on est
bien sûr en plein temps dans ce lieu qui
était c'est symbolique mais je voudrais
aussi revenir sur sept sur sept parties
de luxe moi j'aime pas beaucoup
le mot luxe parce que ici on est dans un
endroit qui provient de la terre qui est
dit à la terre de bourgogne et cette
terre elle est rare et c'est plutôt
c'est très très grand est roi ça peut se
comparer à des oeuvres d'art on a bien
vu qu'on a un léonard de vinci qui s'est
vendu un prix absolument des records
absolus pouvoir qu avant c'était c'était
van gogh et picasso etc
et c'est d'ailleurs des vins de
bourgogne sont le record absolu pour une
vente aux enchères de vieux de vieilles
bouteilles nabil direct et des très
grands vins du domaine de la romanée
conti d'henri jahier etc
ce sont ces presque au niveau artistique
c'est très grand match donc il faut
faire très attention de ne pas confondre
la bourgogne et ses 2 3% de choses
exceptionnelles pour autant l'image de
la bourgogne
elle s'est construit toujours et vous
avez toujours insisté moi je me souviens
quand vous présidiez aux destinées de
cette région
l'interprofession sur la région elle est
unique c'est une pyramide les grands
crus il crée l'image de tout le monde
est-ce que ça c'est à dire des grands
crus à 1000 euros la bouteille c'est pas
en train de briser le train de séparer
les lagons celle d'angers celle d'angers
incontestable moi j'ai toujours pensé
que les grands crus qui ré l'ensemble
des vins de bourgogne mais que les
appellations régionales poussait les
grands crus obligeait les grands crus à
être encore meilleurs encore plus précis
encore plus formidable c'est vrai que
quand on arrive à des prix comme ceux
dont nous parlons on peut penser qu'il
pourrait y avoir une rupture et c'est le
danger c'est l'exemple jérôme gallot
d'autres régions du monde alors on parle
parler et laurent pour en parler aussi
on prend soin l'exemple du bordelais
avec des grands crus extrêmement cher
des grands châteaux extrêmement cher une
viticulture presque prolétarienne à la
base de gens qui ont beaucoup de
difficultés aujourd'hui dé bordeaux à 1
euro 50 comme on a pu les voir dans les
foires aux vins très récemment au mois
de septembre
oui je voudrais revenir sur sur la
dimension prix que vous évoquez tout à
l'air en disant est ce que finalement
les bourgognes que l'on payait peut-être
dix fois moins il ya 15 ans
leur augmentation très forte n'est pas
un danger on peut prendre le problème à
l'envers c'est à dire que la position
qui est la position peu je partage pour
ma part d'aubert de villaine consistant
à dire non le vin n'est pas un produit
de luxe ne doit pas l'être
la romanée-conti robertsau là c'est
toute leur vie ce gage et je m'inscris
complètement dans cette mouvance cela ne
veut pas dire que il ne soit pas soumis
sur des marchés qui sont des marchés
mondiaux à une dynamique qui est celle
d'un produit de luxe
parlant de la spéculation quel est le
problème le problème du prix en disant
finalement les producteurs sont ils
responsables en quelque sorte de
l'augmentation de l'inflation énorme sur
le prêt de main je reprends l'exemple du
marché l'art qui est à ma qui est un
exemple que je trouve excellent si
aujourd'hui vous êtes sur un marché qui
est un marché dont vous savez que qui va
être soumis à très forte spéculation
si vous vendez votre bouteille votre
bouteille prestigieuse qui aujourd'hui
par à 1500 2000 3000 euros si vous la
vendez 150 euros d'accord en se disant
finalement on va pouvoir démocratiser
l'ensemble des consommateurs qui auront
accès vous ferez une erreur parce que
votre bouteille à 150 euros qui peut en
valoir économiquement 3000 sur un marché
par exemple asiatiques
elle va être rachetée par qui vous
croyez qu'elle va être acheté par le
consommateur qui rêvent de pouvoir
déguster un jour cette magnifique
bouteilles non il va être achetée par
des marchands qui vont utiliser ce
produit non pas pour ce à quoi il sert
c'est à dire la consommation
mais pour une relation uniquement
marchande c'est à dire de la revente
donc les prix très élevés de nos plus
beaux flacons est en quelque sorte la
première est peut-être la meilleure
protection contre un mécanisme
spéculatif rendue plus difficile par les
prix atteints laurent les prix
par des prix des bouteilles il ya un
dossier dont tout le monde parle
beaucoup dans le vignoble c'est que le
prix du foncier pour des problèmes de
transmission
je prends une phrase de c'est un autre
responsable du coach jean michel aubinel
quel président de la cnbb qui regroupe
les appellations bourguignonnes a
déclaré c'était dans la semaine même si
ça conforte notre image mondiale de vins
d'exception
nous allons au devant d'une catastrophe
à l'échelle humaine c'est excessif c'est
pas excessif ça veut dire que
globalement les familles traditionnelles
de vignerons vont ne plus pouvoir garder
dans leur famille des vignes de leur
faire de leur histoire dans leur
catastrophe il faut pas tomber justement
verrou trop de gens viticole très bien
oui on a tout à fait la ligue bourgogne
a quand même évolué tout au long de son
histoire et a su être résiliente par
rapport à un certain nombre d'événements
est effectivement en tout cas on a parlé
de la comparaison avec le bordelais la
grosse différence c'est que dans le
bordelais quand quand un propriétaire
d'un château et commercialise à un de
ses grands crus classés
il n'a pas d'autres appellations souvent
il ya des 1er 2e grande différence dans
la structuration des domaines en
bourgogne c'est que effectivement comme
le dit pierre henry gagey on a aussi des
appellations régionales dans un domaine
on a aussi des premiers crus des
appellations villages et à partir du
moment où il n'y a plus cette
possibilité pour des propriétaires
familiaux d'avoir accès aux hauts
sommets de la hiérarchie
et bien finalement il va se retrouver
avec des appellations ou là la
rentabilité économique sera plus
compliqué et donc on va fragiliser en
fait tout l'ensemble en sachant que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui a
commencé depuis un certain temps on
parle aussi - et ça existe beaucoup de
la multiplication des groupements
fonciers viticoles avec beaucoup
d'actionnaires extérieur qui entre à
plusieurs pour permettre à un vigneron
d'étendre son patrimoine mais on a aussi
une dépossession de la propriété d'une
certaine manière tous a ses limites et
c'est finalement pas si mal parce que ça
permet d'abord un certain nombre de deux
personnes physiques qui adore la bourre
et pompeux pas la foi mais c'est normal
nous vendons nos vins dans le monde
entier
60 % les vins de bourgogne sont exportés
on peut pas demander à nos clients qui
aiment la bourgogne qui l'adorent qui en
sont passionnés
donne pas non plus pouvoir s'en
rapprocher encore un peu donc ces
groupements fonciers permettent un
certain nombre de particuliers d'avoir
un plaisir encore plus important en
buvant du vin de bong civilité de vendre
très rapidement à un moment donné s'ils
en ont envie elle vignerons lui aura
plus c'est à la volée ça peut pas à
terme créer une sorte de la ola il faut
faire il faut faire très attention mais
je voudrais être allé je voudrais
revenir quand même sur ce que vous
disiez est ce que le prix du foncier wii
est une véritable catastrophe est devant
le départ et bien sûr c'est très
embêtant mais ce qui est très embêtant
aussi c'est que nous avons en france un
persie qui n'est pas un père si
intelligent on a des successions keane
qu'il des droits de succession des taxes
qui sont absolument délirantes et ça
c'est impensable
on pourrait tout à fait imaginer que
dans des biens très exceptionnel dans
des terres terres qui sont là de la
terre de france et c'est vrai aussi dans
l'agriculture pas seulement dans le
vignoble de dire très simplement écouter
nous voulons transmettre à nos enfants
c'est notre souhait le plus profond
si nous transmettons nos enfants et si
nos enfants conservent le bien pendant
30 ou 40 ans il faut absolument diminuer
ses droits de succession parce que c'est
une catastrophe et sur 250 millions ça
ne donnerait que l'état laisse pas ses
heures pour pas pourquoi ils pourraient
peut-être est intelligent et se dire si
c'est pas si ça reste dans la famille
pendant trente quarante ans c'est
peut-être un moyen de conserver cette
bourgogne unique que nous avons
aujourd'hui entre les mains
autre point ces vins qui pour certains
en particulier grands crus ont vu leur
prix augmenter tout ça étant lié on l'a
dit aussi avec le prix du foncier escape
un déplacement des consommateurs et
est-ce qu'il n'ya pas à s'entendre deux
pays je pense à la france aux gens qui
nous regardent qui nous écoutent qui
finalement moins en moins accès à ces
vins là et est ce que ça ça part en
germe un problème pour pour la région je
pense qu'il faut séparer de choses ici
d'une part la volonté des producteurs
des vignerons des négociants de pouvoir
servir monsieur gage et on parlait tout
à l'heure une partie des consommateurs
du monde qui ont envie de profiter aussi
de s'émerveiller produits de ces
merveilleux vingt deuxième chose il faut
séparer donc cette dimension là d'une
autre dimension qui est le pouvoir
d'achat existant en france pour acheter
nos plus beaux flacons challenge a fait
au mois de septembre une super reportage
sur les millionnaires et l'augmentation
du millionnaire j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle pour nous tous les
millionnaires augmente aux etats unis
ils sont presque 5 millions les
millionnaires augmentent en chine et
sont aujourd'hui un peu plus d'un
million mais les millionnaires augmente
aussi en france sur le marché français
et je ne dis pas que seuls les
millionnaires et ce n'est absolument pas
le cas on les moyens de consommer ont
les moyens de consommer pour en tout cas
à me faire partir la moitié en tout cas
ce que je suis ce que je suis en train
de vous dire c'est que les français qui
le souhaitent ont les moyens aujourd'hui
de s'acheter ses bouteilles avec une
affaire d'émotion si vous le permettez
qui est si le consommateur le
consommateur a toujours la liberté de
choisir ce qui va acheter le smic en
france est aujourd'hui à 1000 euros nets
vous parlez de bouteilles que vous
classer dans des vins de luxe je pense
que ce sont pas des vains luxe mais une
bouteille à 100 euros ce qui est
probablement beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
ce faux car c'est un pro tour beaucoup
de mon agent et moi j'ai envie de dire
la découverte et cette expérience unique
dont parlait mon collègue de droite
aussi tout à l'heure que l'on va voir si
j'ai le choix entre cette expérience
d'un merveilleux flacon à 100 euros et
de l'autre le fait de m'acheter un
smartphone à 300 400 500 il ya combien
le nouveau smartphone de l'entreprise à
la petite pomme
il est à 1200 euros moi je vais dire
qu'à un moment donné 100 euros si je
pousse le bouchon trop loin par rapport
à la qualité de l'expérience que je vais
avoir et à la magie que je vais vivre
c'est peut-être pas encore assez cher
alors il faut rajouter aussi différentes
choses
la bourgogne dans son ensemble
qualitativement a beaucoup progressé ces
trente dernières années ce qui veut dire
que certaines appellations moins connu
des petits villages ont beaucoup
augmenté en qualité 2 les jeunes les
jeunes générations aujourd'hui boivent
moins mais mieux mais préfère
ne pas boire du vin tous les jours mais
quand ils en boivent voir de bonnes
bouteilles et il est possible
aujourd'hui en bourgogne de boire des
vins entre 20 et 40 euros qui sont
précis superbe des manifs expression de
leur terroir donc oublions ces très
grandes bouteilles qui sont cons bois
une fois exceptionnellement on en boit
une bouteille dans l'année voilà bah oui
un grand cru c'est un truc très très
particulier et alors moi j'ai envie de
revenir
est ce qu'on les bois ses bouteilles
laurent parce qu'on le sait il ya un
marché aussi aujourd'hui plus les
bouteilles sont chères plus elles sont
prestigieuses plus elles sont
spéculatifs plus elle circule moins on
les bois c'est vrai c'est pas vrai ah
oui c'était très vrai pour les poulets
bordeaux ça l'a été beaucoup moins pour
l'épauler bourgogne pendant très
longtemps
moi je suis dans ce monde depuis une
quinzaine d'années et on disait au début
des années 2000 que la bourgogne avait
pas de ya pas de spéculation sur les
vins je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui a qui a changé il faut le dire
effectivement ensuite moi j'ai envie de
dire
pour rebondir un peu sur ce que 10e ce
gage et c'est que la bourgogne c'est
aussi 50 % d'appellation régional donc
de vins qui sont autour d'une dizaine
d'euros
c'est aussi des crémants de bourgogne
qui sont qui représente pas loin de 10%
lors de la production
vous participez souvent des dégustations
rien contre et aussi des gens des
amateurs la bourgogne des amoureux de la
bourgogne vous en accompagner c'est quoi
leur rapport c'est d'abord on commence
par ces vins là mais en réalité les gens
ils fantasment aussi sur ceux dont on
parle sur les grands crus ils ont très
vite envie d'y aller non coupe à dire
que pour l'instant tout est encore bien
connecté non non faut le dire il faut le
dire aujourd'hui parler de parler de
grand cru de la côte de nuits pour pour
la plupart des amateurs c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui reste
inaccessible mais effectivement c'est
aussi ce qui braque les et les
projecteurs sur la bourgogne esquisse
qui permet peut-être de gens voient des
gens à découvrir en disant que peut-être
un jour effectivement en cassant leur
tirelire effectivement comme disait
monsieur gage et une fois dans l'année
ils pourront se payer un grand vin un
grand vin de bourgogne à saint lary
en venant nous voir en ya plein de gens
qui sont contents de partager leurs très
grandes bouteilles
si vous démontrez un vrai amour pour les
grands vins vous pouvez trouver des gens
qui sont très sympas qui vont être ravis
de vous lancer mais c'est vrai pour une
croisade
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai on le voit
tous les jours - on connaît des
collectionneurs américains étrangers qui
sont des gens fantastiques qui ont la
chance de pouvoir avoir dans leurs cales
des très grandes bouteilles leur plus
grand plaisir c'est de les partager avec
d'autres
beaucoup qui sont pas ouvertes qui sont
achetés et revendus oui il y en a mais
mais il y en a beaucoup qui sont but
jérôme gallot vous qui connaissez bien
le marché du vin marché pas uniquement
français mondial du vin la bourgogne
elle se situe comment elle se situe
encore dans les régions un peu mythique
sur ce côté un peu sacré dont vous
parliez et puis cohérente dans son image
où elle ou l'image change un petit peu
est-ce qu'on peut le dire ou es ce qui
est difficile à dire
c'est difficile à dire par contre nous
avons nous une manière de l'évaluer tous
les ans avec la centaine d'étudiants
internationaux qui nous rejoignent dans
les trois probables de la school of one
of us business
parmi eux nous avons des américains qui
est je crois le premier marché export
pour les vins de bourgogne
les chinois qui sont l'objet d'un
fantasme un peu particulier ne sont que
les onzièmes de ce point de vue là donc
il ya encore beaucoup de beaucoup de
marge
je crois que l'image est en train de se
renforcer je trouve que à l'image du vin
qui n'a jamais été aussi bon et je crois
que l'image de la broye n'a jamais été
aussi près de ce qu'elle est réellement
dans toutes ses dimensions et les
étudiants ce qu'ils viennent chercher
quand il vient chercher c'est nous c'est
pas le fait de pouvoir déguster
éventuellement des vins
à des prix extrêmement élevé c'est
l'expérience l'expérience qui consiste à
pouvoir déguster des vins de bourgogne
quelles que soient leurs prix dans un
cadre qui restent sur leurs lieux de
consommation
je crois que c'est ça qui est important
et je crois que c'est une dimension qui
est en train de se renforcer
particulièrement d'ailleurs au détriment
peut-être le mot est peut-être un peu
fort mais mais des bordelais qui n'ont
pas forcément l'essayer que de très bons
souvenirs sur les marchés alors
asiatiques
est ce que c'est un enjeu pour la
bourgogne c'est à dire qu'on a bien
compris que c'est un phénomène
économique mondiale et qu' il semble
difficile à maîtriser ou à juguler
est-ce que l'enjeu ça va être de garder
l'image l'accueil de l'améliorer de
conserver sa et l'image de la bourgogne
fondamente c'est absolument fondamental
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on est
tellement contents et fiers que les
climats de bourgogne au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
parce que d'abord bien sûr c'est la
reconnaissance du travail qui a été fait
par des générations de vignerons mais
c'est aussi une obligation pour nous de
délivrer une expérience formidable pour
ceux qui viennent en bourgogne la
bourgogne c'est une terre d'accueil on
est situé dans un lieu de passage
il ya plein de léon 20 ski et on va sur
la côte d'azur on remonte en belgique en
passant pour vannes et on s'arrête en
beauval une journée de journée et
surtout on ne fait pas l'erreur de ne
rester que à bôle et entre
nuits-saint-georges vosne-romanée ou
puligny montrachet
on va aussi dans des endroits un peu
moins connus on va dans les hautes côtes
de beaune dans les hautes côtes de nuits
on va dans la coordination base et vous
voudriez qu'on aille où les gens vont
vraiment on voudrait leur ai dit il faut
qu'il passe qui trouveront là bas des
vignerons qui sont sans doute moins
sollicité que ceux qui sont sur la côte
dans les villages très connu et qui vont
les accueillir avec encore plus de
gentillesse encore plus de bonheur et
ils vont passer un moment formidable
élan jeu il est là parce que c'est c'est
toute la bourgogne
doit réussir c'est pas uniquement la
bohème des grands crus c'est l'ensemble
de cette grande bourgogne et c'est ça
qui nous excite bien sûr si les
responsables des domaines les plus
prestigieux on va dire de la locomotive
sont des investisseurs ou des sociétés
d'investissement est ce qu'il ya un
risque quand même de d'identité ce sera
plus difficile de discuter avec eux
quand c'était des familles
traditionnelles vigneronne ou des
familles qui étaient dans le monde du
vin ja on est d'accord on est d'accord
on est d'accord il ya un risque mais
mais soyons clairs pour le moment sept
ans que c'est vraiment très très limité
les familles sont toujours là les
vignerons sont toujours là beaucoup ont
parlé des grands crus tout à l'heure
plein de domaines en côte-d'or ont un
nectar un tiers d'hectare deux tiers
d'hectare de grands crus cela ne vont
pas les vendre ils vont les garder parce
qu'ils ont aussi des plus mal ils auront
peut-être du mal elles transmettent mais
ils vont tout faire pour les transmettre
et on en connaît plein et nous tous
autour de nous de famille de vignerons
qui vont dire je vais tout faire pour le
transmettre à mes enfants
non mais je lui ai juste simplement
témoigner que les moments les plus
magiques on peut passer en bourgogne
pour un journalisme comme pour quelqu'un
qui vient déguster un simple amateur
c'est quand on a en face de soi la
personne qui a fait le vin qui nous
explique un petit peu sa vision du vin
comment il a travaillé la vigne comment
il exprimé son terroir
voilà est temps que ça existera en
bourgogne et c'est quand même le cas
dans 95% des des domaines tant qu'on
aura cet ce contact avec la personne en
face qui a fait le vin qui sait nous en
parle et qui sait nous donner sa vision
du vin là je pense qu'on restera avec
une bourgogne corps à ce côté magique et
éternelle voilà ce que c'est ce qu'il
faut préserver je pense
on va dire qu'il ya plus tellement
d'opportunités de culbute financière
énorme comme celles qui viennent de se
faire cesser
ces derniers ces dernières années en
réalité vous disiez ça tient sur demain
les très grands domaines avec une
identité très forte qui peuvent être
achetés plusieurs centaines de millions
à oui oui oui je pense que il y en a il
y en a pas beaucoup surtout pas autant
que de grands châteaux bordelais à un
moment donné au moins beaucoup moins
c'est beaucoup plus limité une fois de
plus les grands crus de bourgogne une
partie sont concentrés dans quelques
grands domaines mais tout le reste était
par piller parmi une multitude de
domaines et heureusement c'est la force
de la bourgogne c'est le génie de la
bourgogne de voir ce morcellement
d'appellation jérôme gallot c'est de la
passion vu de votre point de vue société
d'investissement aujourd'hui qui met 200
250 millions dans un domaine viticole
c'est un amour du vin c'est vraiment
quelque chose de financier en attendant
un fort retour sur investissement vous
vous l'analysez comment alors je ne suis
pas dans la tête dit non mais je suis
sûr que vous en avez si on prend un
petit peu de hauteur
il peut y avoir un intérêt économique
même si comme le disait mes deux voisins
la culbute économique elle est
difficilement envisageable même à moyen
terme lorsque les montants sont aussi la
passion du vin à écouter je l'espère et
je le pense comme premier argument comme
premier argument
et puis il y a aussi des dimensions à la
dimension un petit peu
la dimension business en ce qui concerne
le clos tard si vous permettez je pense
que monsieur pinault
était heureux de pouvoir se retrouver de
l'autre côté du mur air de son meilleur
mois je crois aussi que c'est une
diversification du patrimoine
voilà c'est une diversification du
patrimoine quand vous êtes une famille
très fortunés mais ce n'était pas le cas
en bourgogne avant on est beaucoup à
l'éméritat - parce que c'était compliqué
c'est compliqué de d'acheter des vignes
en bourgogne parce que s'est morcelé
alors une fois de plus c'est plus simple
quand vous avez un bon morceau mais
quand s'est morcelé c'est très complexe
donc cesser de l'extérieur on le voit
pas bien on a du mal à comprendre
beaucoup parce qu'il nous reste une
minute trente de l'émission on est dans
la salle des ventes
il ya la vente des vins cet après midi 6
un monde beaucoup vous en connaissez
depuis très longtemps des ventes voyager
si ça monte beaucoup c'est bien ou c'est
pas bien non faut pas que ça monte
beaucoup sincèrement il y à une récolte
importante
il ya vraiment de quoi faire moi
j'espère que ça va être stable ça peut
monter un petit peu ça ça pose pas de
problème mais monte beaucoup ça me
paraîtrait vraiment déraisonnable ça
serait pas un bon signal
bien sûr on veut que les hospices de
beaune qui a dû beaucoup d'argent c'est
une oeuvre caritative naturellement elle
va gagner beaucoup d'argent cet
après-midi parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
pièces à vendre
essayons de maintenir les prix peut-être
une petite hausse mais mais pas une
hausse énorme non on se donne rendez
vous allez 20h 19h 21h parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de 20 cette année pour pourvoir
sa merci à tous les trois d'être venus
participer à cette émission
n'oublions pas pendant toute la journée
sur la page facebook de france 3 vous
aurez plein de petits direct pour voir
ce qui se passe pendant la vente et puis
ce soir
20h25 pendant une demi heure sur france
3 bourgogne on vous raconte les trois
jours de la vente des vins des hospices
de beaune avec les coulisses l'intérieur
l'extérieur vous verrez tout ça on vous
y attend
mon dimanche au revoir et merci à tous
les trois
[Musique]